european union is a magnificent piece of
work
but it will not be perfect
as long as women and men
face inequality of outcomes
and the value of gender equality is not
secure
making gender equality a reality for all
is still ahead of us
i'm very very proud of the competent and
professional group we have so please
could you stand out so people would know
then
so this is the team
a good policy making process cannot but
start from uh having solid evidence
about the
what the reality is and what the needs
for correction or for transformation for
change
are and i think
this is the reason why
the index is an
instrument that will contribute to more
solid policy making
and making out of it a living tool
that reflects the evolution of the
situation and so the definition that
we've adopted is this one equal as a
share of assets and equal dignity and
integrity between women and men
this is a definition that we thought was
simple enough to
and pragmatic enough to reconcile the
different perspectives that there could
be and the best
index
the most robust
is the one
which minimizes the differences to the
medium
the best index
is
the winner is this one
this is the gender equality index this
is the mathematical expression of this
indicator is
a little bit complex but its
interpretation is very easy
these three characteristics these three
virtues
are a strong reasons for
falling in love with this gender
equality index
what we want to we to measure is
violence against women and
we conceptualize two different
subdomains direct and indirect violence
and when it comes to the result there is
nothing to see here why because we don't
have
in europe
nowadays we don't ever we can't rely on
harmonize comparable reliable data
available for all the 27 member states
the eu average is 54
which is half a way towards equality
the majority of the country are below
this threshold or this core this level
we can't
consider a treasure because our
threshold our benchmark is 100 percent
what we have launched today uh are
really in my mind a really credible tool
to give us an indicator of gender
equality is going to be enormously
valuable
i don't want to be mean to men on this
issue
but the thing that i have noticed is
that we do approach things differently
which for me is of tremendous value
it's of tremendous value because if we
can exploit our diversity
in a very broad spectrum of areas and
i'm thinking here in the european
dimension
we are in my mind
unbeatable
for years we knew we needed to gather
the information
and for years we looked at what was
going on in other countries to have it
at our fingertips now will be an
invaluable tool an invaluable tool and
year on year we will be able to measure
how we're doing good at some things bad
at others that's the way index work but
hopefully hopefully that the european
union itself will take this very
seriously because if we're going to live
longer we need to ensure that more and
more people particularly women do not
continue to fall into poverty thank you
very much the principle of equality is
prominently enshrined in the eu treaties
but we all know that gender equality has
yet to be fully realized in practice
for that
we have mainly our own blindness to
blame
to oblate in fact
half of our citizens
are women
and because we don't understand well
enough the situation of women we don't
understand ourselves
women remain less likely
to participate
in the labor market than men
and when women do participate
it's more frequently on part-time basis
leading to increased patterns of
segregation and very often lower quality
of jobs actually many more women than
men
spend their time
on average at the eu level
on one
in one hour or more a day
doing housework and cooking
this proves that
the bulk of care
is still on the shoulders of women and
men are greatly over-represented as
board members through all member states
this refers to the representation of
women and men
in the quoted companies of the countries
you cannot
tell us that
for sure we will be we will be having
good data on gender violence soon
unfortunately the only thing i can do
because your stat is a department of the
commission is that on the commission
side all the technical work has been
done the preparatory work has been done
which is quite uh
i mean requires much time and effort but
the commission proposes legislation and
then it's it goes to the council and to
the parliament for decision and this of
course is no more eurostat
responsibility so on the statistical
side the work has been done so these
things are connected and if we don't
have the data on violence we will never
see this
so we will never see how much violence
is also an economic issue
we will not see how much violence is
affecting all the other areas of gender
inequality and today's conference also
very clearly show what we need to do
if we what we need to do if we want
really gender equality it's not that we
don't have the knowledge it's all about
political will thank you for
coming
participating listening but most of all
for your future contribution to
monitoring gender equality via the gaps
between women and men and trying to make
it a reality